hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
über das Gebäude Energiegesetz ganz
schön langes Wort oft auch
heizungsgesetz genannt wird in
Deutschland ja seit Monaten diskutiert
habt ihr bestimmt schon mitgekommen
mitbekommen und das sollte eigentlich
ein wesentlicher Teil des
klimaschutzgesetzes sein und quasi uns
die wärmewende bescheren also dass wir
auch mit der Energie in der Heizung weg
von fossilen Energien kommen seit heute
ist aber klar der ursprüngliche Zeitplan
für dieses Gesetz ist wohl nicht mehr
einzuhalten denn die FDP blockiert die
erste Lesung dieses eigentlich
einstimmig vom Kabinett verabschiedeten
Gesetzentwurfes vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause wird man
sich wahrscheinlich also zu diesem Punkt
nicht mehr einigen ja und die
Koalitionspartner Grüne und SPD die sind
aktuell ziemlich genervt
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat heute
sogar von Zitat Wortbruch gesprochen wir
wollen deswegen heute hier bei ZDF heute
live auf folgende Punk zu gucken geht es
bei diesem Streit da gerade eigentlich
um inhaltliche Aspekte oder ist das auch
viel Parteipolitik spielt die FDP da
gerade ein bisschen auf Zeit darüber
spreche ich heute mit euch und mit
Daniel fößt der SV und
wohnungspolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion und mit der
grünen Politikerin Ingrid Nestle sie ist
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie außerdem erklärt uns noch
die Wirtschaftsweise Professor Veronika
Grimm wo die Schwächen dieses geplanten
heizungstauschgesetzes liegen und was
geändert werden muss und da sind schon
meine Gäste herzlich willkommen bei ZDF
heute live guten Abend
und ich begrüße auch noch mal euch da
draußen und nochmal der herzliche
Hinweis wenn ihr Fragen an unsere Gäste
habt oder einfach mal eure Meinung zum
Thema mit uns teilen wollt dann macht
das gerne hier im Youtube Chip Chat oder
unter der eingeblendeten Mail-Adresse
jetzt frage ich aber gleich mal meine
Gäste zum heutigen Tag Herr Fürst was
sagen sie nach diesem Tag von den
Koalitionspartnern gibt es ja ganz schön
genervt Reaktion können Sie die irgendwo
auch verstehen
ich verstehe nicht ganz wo die ganz
Unruhe herkommt wir haben den Konsens
gefunden sowohl im Koalitionsvertrag als
auch im Koalitionsausschuss das nicht
zunehmend Gebäudesektor keine Option
mehr ist und dazu stehen wir auch wir
stehen auch zu der grundsätzlichen
Vereinbarung dass die Gebäude möglichst
zu 65 % erneuerbaren Energien betrieben
werden sollen oder eben wie es
formuliertesten Koalitionsvertrag durch
andere Maßnahme gleicher Menge CO2
einsparen sollen das hatten wir auch für
richtig der Plan ist dass wir vor der
Sommerpause dieses heizungsgesetz vor
oder die Heizung jetzt abstimmen
allerdings jemand nicht davon
ausgegangen dass in diesem
heizungsgesetz so viele Sachen drin
stehen die nicht durch den
Koalitionsvertrag gedeckt sind auch wenn
wir sagen wir sind bereit als FDP auf
die Tube zu drücken schnell zu arbeiten
viel zu machen muss doch jedem
vernünftigen Menschen klar sein dass das
kein Blankoscheck ist ein beliebig
schlechtes Gesetz zu formulieren also
wir stehen zu dem Gesetz es wird auch
was kommen allerdings was jetzt das
Diskussionsgrundlage im Raum ist da
haben wir so viel Verbesserungsbedarf
als sehr viele Schwächen hat
von einem beliebig schlechten Gesetz
Frau Nestle wie genervt ist in ihre
Partei über diese Blockade der FDP heute
die erste Lesung des Gesetzes ja genau
meiner Meinung nach ist es schon ein
sehr
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang weil wenn es so
ist wie sie sagen Herr Fürst und sie
schnell und viel verhandeln können dann
müssen diese Verhandlungen erstmal
anfangen ja genau das ist ja das Ziel
gewesen das jetzt mit der ersten Lesung
die parlamentarischen Beratungen
beginnen können dass er Voraussetzung
dafür dass man über die inhaltet und
tatsächlich ist dieses Gesetz dieser
Gesetzentwurf und nicht irgendein
anderer ist im Kabinett einstimmig
beschlossen worden sind
Koalitionsausschuss was explizit Thema
dass dieses Gesetz und damals waren die
Eckpunkte bekannt
dass dieses Gesetz vor der Sommerpause
kommt und ich weiß dass viele in ihrer
Partei sich gerne mit dem ehrbaren
Kaufmann identifizieren und tatsächlich
sehe ich davon heute nicht mehr so viel
auch der Kanzler hat klar gesagt das
Gesetz muss jetzt schnell beraten werden
und das ist schon ungewöhnlich den
Beginn der Beratung bereits zu
blockieren
aber Frau Kollegin Nestle ich weiß sie
nehmen hallo reingehen möchte da eine
Richtigstellung
okay also es finden Gespräche statt
zwischen den arbeitsaktionen ich war
heute erst zwei Stunden in einem
sogenannten berichterstattergespräch zu
dem Thema Gebäude Energiegesetz also
dass wir da als FDP nicht beraten würden
ich weiß nicht wie man darauf kommt ja
wir halten die aufsetzung jetzt am 25.05
für falsch was Sinn machen würde
dass wir bei allen drei Parteien gibt's
große Änderungswünsche dass wir die
großen Linien erstmal klar ziehen bevor
wir im Bundestag uns darüber streiten
da schalte ich mich jetzt einmal ein
denn für die Zuschauer da draußen wenn
ihr euch jetzt gerade fragt über was
genau sprechen die da gerade Thomas
Gonsior hat uns dieses heizungsgesetz
aber auch die Kritik daran noch mal
zusammengefasst
das geplante Gebäude Energiegesetz sieht
vor das möglichst jede neu eingebaute
Heizung mit mindestens 65% erneuerbarer
Energie betrieben wird und zwar ab
Januar nächstes Jahr zu früh so die
Kritik man müsste länger planen können
in jedem Fall dürfen alte Öl und
Gasheizungen zunächst noch weiterlaufen
und auch repariert werden was aber
geschieht wenn eine Reparatur nicht mehr
möglich ist dass es unklar und deswegen
ein weiterer Kritikpunkt im Gesetzestext
heißt es nur es werde pragmatische
Übergangslösungen und mehrjährige
Übergangsfristen geben
2044 soll jedenfalls endgültig Schluss
sein mit fossilen Brennstoffen über
80-jährige in ihrem Eigenheim müssen
aber nicht auf erneuerbare Energien
umstellen Kritik auch daran warum gilt
die Ausnahme nicht generell für ältere
etwa für Rentner in bestehende Gebäude
dürfen weiterhin Gasheizungen eingebaut
werden zum Beispiel in Kombination mit
einer Wärmepumpe die Heizung austauschen
für den Klimaschutz das soll gefördert
werden mit 30 bis 50%. die Union
bemängelte aber zuletzt wer wann wie
gefördert wird das sei nicht verbindlich
geregelt Befürchtung außerdem wenn
Vermieter zusätzliche kostenanmieter
weitergeben könnten manche mieten so
steigen dass
ärmere Haushalte überfordert werden das
geplante Gebäude Energiegesetz es gibt
noch viele Fragen viele Änderungswünsche
und ganz viel Kritik
ja und darüber können wir jetzt gerne
diskutieren ihr habt jetzt gehört worum
es bei diesem Gesetz eigentlich geht und
was die verschiedenen Kritikpunkte daran
sind und deswegen noch mal meine Frage
an Herrn Fürst was sind denn in der FDP
ganz konkret die Inhalte die die FDP an
diesem Gesetz kritisiert
tatsächlich waren einige Kritikpunkte
die wir wirklich für hochproblematisch
halten auch Teil jetzt diesen Beitrags
die Übergangsfristen sind noch nicht
aufeinander abgestimmt es gibt auch ein
zweites Gesetz das viele für grundlegend
halten für dieses heizungsgesetz dass
die sogenannte kommunale wärmeplanung
wir halten das für sehr sinnvoll dass
bei den Fristen und Übergang auch Bezug
genommen wird auf die kommunale
wärmeplanung auch die Frage tatsächlich
der Überforderung der Bürger und Bürger
es ist ja ein Grundgedanken korrekt dass
man sagt 80-Jährige wären wahrscheinlich
überfordert wenn Sie jetzt noch mal die
Heizung tauschen müssen also nehme ich
erstmal raus allerdings gibt's noch
durchaus weitere Fragen der
Unmöglichkeit technische Möglichkeit ist
immer ein Thema dann aber auch die Frage
kriegt man überhaupt noch ein Kredit
also auch in 70-jähriger kriegt kein
Kredit mehr wie ist es in Bereichen wo
der Staat Regeln er lässt die jetzt mal
die bestmögliche Sanierung nicht möglich
machen zum Beispiel Denkmalschutz oder
in ähm haltungsgebieten da gibt's
wirklich eine Menge offene Punkte über
die wir reden würden und bevor wir das
im Bundestag tun wäre es mir lieber wir
machen das Internet in der Ampel
einmal ganz einfach darauf reagieren
darf ja sie wissen ganz genau dass wir
im Parlament verhandeln Gesetze und dass
wir sie erst einbringen wie das im
Kabinett kommen und da haben die FDP
Minister ja auch zugestimmt ja und die
erste Einbringung schon zu blockieren
das ist tatsächlich nicht so her lassen
Sie uns mal voll beinhalten das gab es
so noch nie zu den Inhalten wir brauchen
machen das Gesetz ja nicht aus Jux und
Dollerei ja wir machen das Gesetz ja aus
drei sehr gewichtigen Gründen zum einen
wir hatten die gaspreiskrise erst im
letzten Herbst und Winter wir haben
unfassbar viel Steuergeld dafür
ausgegeben um ja zumindest ein Teil
dieser Preissteigerung abzufedern und
der Gas wird dauerhaft teurer bleiben
und es kann jederzeit wieder sehr teuer
werden deswegen Gebiete schon die
bezahlbar kein dass wir einfach
erneuerbare setzen wir wollen auch
unabhängiger werden von Gas Diktatoren
und autokarten ja wir wollen
Abhängigkeiten kommen und natürlich wir
brauchen Klimaschutz und das ist
tatsächlich der sanfte Ansatz zu sagen
ja nur dort wo sowieso eine neue Heizung
eingebaut wird da gehen wir jetzt nicht
wieder auf 20 30 Jahre auf die falsche
Technologie sondern da so zumindest ein
Teiler neuerbare eingebaut werden die
Fristen
schon längst im Koalitionsausschuss
geeinigt genau so geeint ja Sonderregeln
gibt es längst in diesem Gesetz und da
frage ich mich schon wo wir in der
Koalition stehen ja wenn das Wort nicht
mehr geht
ich weiß ich möchte nicht alles
kommentieren aber ich möchte bitte die
größten vielleicht Missverständnisse
doch adressieren dürfen es ist völlig
normal dass wir uns in der Ampel über
ein Gesetz unterhalten und dann daran
die weiteren Fortgang im Bundestag
knüpfen also ich bin berichterstatt
dafür eigentlich
einige Themen Bauen und Wohnen Gebäude
Energie Bauleitplanung Baugebiet
planungsbeschleunigung da haben wir
immer angefangen intern darüber zu
diskutieren völlig egal ob die erste
Lesung stattgefunden hat oder nicht also
dass wir erst immer warten bis die erste
Lesung ist und dann noch mal drüber
diskutieren das tut mir leid das ist
nicht Teil meiner geliebten Realität
hier im Deutschen Bundestag kann sein
dass wir das anders weil wir sind
anderen Ausschüssen kann sein dass wir
es anders erleben aber wir als FDP haben
wir handhaben immer sehr pragmatisch es
wird darüber geredet so als Sinn macht
und dann wird die erste Lesung
durchgeführt übrigens für die erste von
drei Lesungen also damit man auch
vielleicht weil sich jeder weiß was
aufsetzen erste Lesung etc bedeutet wir
fangen an darüber zu diskutieren und
dann ist es nicht so entscheiden wann
die erste Lesung ist nur in diesem
besonderen Fall weil es da einfach bei
SPD ganz großen Änderungsbedarf gibt und
diesen Gesetz bei uns ganz großen
Veränderungsbedarf gibt dann im Gesetz
und Frau netzbesuch ihre
Berichterstatter verstanden habe hätten
sie auch noch Änderungswünsche an dem
Gesetz während erhalten wir für sinnvoll
dass wir erst diese großen
177 Seiten diese groß ist gepanzpunkt
abräumen bevor wir in erste Lesung gehen
weil wir sonst der AFD unter Union
führen vor öffnen das will ich als FDP
einfach nicht ich gucke gerade parallel
schon mal in unseren Chat die User sind
schon ganz fleißig am kommentieren und
da hat es einen User auf Facebook sehr
salopp kommentiert ich gebe das trotzdem
mal hier in die Runde und zwar fragt
Kathrin kein Berg auf Facebook warum hat
die FDP nicht von Anfang an den Mund
aufgemacht das ist ja schon so dass der
Entwurf einstimmig vom Kabinett
verabschiedet wurde also es gab ja die
Möglichkeit zu Diskussion
also wir haben von Anfang an den Mund
aufgemacht dann gab es irgendwann ein
Punkt das ist übrigens das kann man auch
sich online anschauen Christian Lindner
hat er sehr gut dargestellt bei Ludwig
Erhard Kongress dann gab es irgendwann
den Punkt an dem Olaf Scholz und habe
die Debatte nicht mehr im Kabinett im
Kabinett haben wollte und hat Christian
Lindner gefragt sag mal Olaf Scholz sag
mal Robert habe Weg wie sieht's aus
sollen wir das jetzt hier im Kabinett
fertig machen oder gehen wir nun
fertiges Gesetz ähm in den Bundestag und
dann war es der Grund von Olaf Scholz
und Robert Habeck das ist in den
Bundestag geht und dann haben wir den
zugestimmt um SPD im Grünen da entgegen
zu kommen haben aber in einer Protokoll
Notiz festgehalten dass wir dieses
Gesetz so nicht mittragen werden und
genau an dem funktioniert jetzt da hat
sich auch bei der FDP gar nichts
geändert natürlich
im parlamentarischen Verfahren
Änderungen machen wollen und genau das
verhindern sie gerade und natürlich sie
finden das wirklich normal dass der
Koalitionsausschuss eint bis zur
Sommerpause da steht ein Zeitplan
dahinter und das dann die erste Lesung
verhindert wird ja und man macht nie
Änderungen im Gesetz vor der ersten
sondern man kann vorher reden ja aber
Änderungen macht man nie vorher sondern
die macht man zwischen der ersten der
zweiten dritten Lesung ja das heißt es
ein ganz klarer Bruch dessen was im
Koalitionsausschuss verhandelt worden
ist das finden sie normal
ich weiß dass ihr ein Gespräch nicht
teilnehmen aber die finden statt es ist
nicht so gesprächig
ich bekomme auch mit Wasserstoff
zusammengesetzt gesessen um über dieses
Gesetz zu reden also ich finde diese
Aussage ich finde dich stark
sein
Kommunikation
25.05.2 Schuss steht wir bekennen uns zu
dem Ziel 65 % erneuerbare Energie ist
auch richtig stellen wir nicht in Frage
wenn der Gebäudesektor nicht liefert
dann werden wir die Klimaziele nie nie
erreichen bestellten FDP keine Frage nur
es ist kein planko da kann es ist keine
blanke Unterschrift dass wir jedes
Gesetz ohne Änderung mittragen des
vorgelegt wird und es muss doch bitte
ist noch erwachsene Menschen das muss
doch SPD und Grünen klar sein dass das
Ziel Sommerpause nicht bedeutet wie
unterschreiben alles blind
eine kurze Antwort wir erwarten dass sie
die Verhandlungen beginnen ja nicht nur
Gespräche und dass der Zeitplan
einzuhalten ist und Firma für einen
reguläres Verfahren hätte man es heute
einbringen müssen um es vor der
Sommerpause fertig zu bekommen genau das
war vereinbart genau das haben sie
gebrochen das lassen Sie mich auch
Ausreden zweiter Punkt ja sie haben ja
noch nicht mal unsere konkreten
Forderungen genannt sie reden die ganze
Zeit davon dass sie noch ganz viele
Fragen haben angeblich 100 oder 101 noch
nicht mal diese Fragen haben Sie uns zur
Verfügung gestellt weil sie überhaupt
nicht verhandeln wollen
das ist nicht korrekt wir haben bereits
über 40 Fragen wir haben diese Fragen
nicht ich habe auch Kollegen aus dem
Bauausschuss gerade eben noch mal
gefragt die Fragen liegen uns immer noch
nicht vor über diese sagen Tagen reden
das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall gerade für
die Zuschauer und auch für mich ein ganz
schöner Einblick in das politische
Geschehen der sicher auch für viele von
uns jetzt schwer nachzuvollziehen ist
deswegen würde ich sagen wir gucken noch
mal auf den Inhalt nur vielleicht vorab
schon mal einen Eindruck aus der
Community von YouTube User Tom fühlt der
schreibt ich finde es sollte
einigermaßen Einigkeit zwischen den
Parteien der Koalition herrschen bevor
wir hier öffentlich seit Wochen
diskutieren ein Punkt auf den ich gerne
noch mal eingehen würde ist der
Kritikpunkt dass ich bei diesem
Gesetzesentwurf sehr sehr stark auf die
Wärmepumpen fokussiert wurde das ist ja
eine Diskussion die haben wir schon seit
Wochen Frau Nestle warum hat man da so
stark auf die Wärmepumpen gesetzt
also tatsächlich fokussiert das Gesetz
gar nicht alleine auf die Wärmepumpen es
ist jede Technologie zulässig mit der
man die 65% Erneuerbaren erreicht und es
gibt zusätzlich eine ganze Reihe von
besonders einfachen erfüllungsoptionen
sage ich mal die so unbürokratisch sind
dass man die 65% gar nicht nachweisen
muss und davon gibt es auch verschiedene
zuerst die genannt wird zum Beispiel die
Wärme Netze und gar nicht die
Wärmepumpen und die Wärmepumpe ist auch
eine davon eine weitere ist z.B die
hybridheizung das heißt dass man nur so
die basiswärmeversorgung mit der
Wärmepumpe macht und ja den kalten Tagen
die Spitzen mit einem Gaskessel zu macht
das geht auch im unseren Altbau und wenn
man dann das später irgendwann saniert
kann man den Gaskessel einfach
rausnehmen die Wärmepumpe ist schon
richtig dimensioniert aber auch Biomasse
mit Solar kombiniert also es gibt da die
verschiedensten Optionen aber natürlich
halten wir die Ehrlichkeit dazu zu sagen
das ist auch eine ganze Reihe
Konstellation geben wird wo die
Wärmepumpe einfach die günstigste
Technologie ist ja wo jetzt wo die
Gaspreise so hochgegangen sind und auch
deswegen lohnt sich ja so viele Leute
gerade schon Wärmepumpen ein wenn viele
Nachbarländern gibt es schon viel viel
mehr Wärmepumpen als bei uns weil es
einfach angesichts teurer Gaspreise die
auch drohen jederzeit noch deutlich
teurer zu werden in vielen vielen
Konstellationen die kostengünstige
Option ist und eben bei weitem nicht nur
im Neubau und deswegen hat sich glaube
ich auch wieder Diskussion darum gedreht
aber das Gesetz sieht tatsächlich eine
ganze Reihe von Technologien vor und
hatte auch gar nicht die Intention die
Wärmepumpe so als ganz nach vorne zu
stellen ganz vorne stehen eigentlich die
Wärmenetze Stichwort Wärmepumpe in
deutschen Haushalten dazu haben wir mal
was vorbereitet um einfach mal zu sehen
wie wir da im internationalen Vergleich
aktuell also da stehen
das dürfte jetzt irgendwann hier
reinkommen genau wir sehen die Anzahl
eingebauter Wärmepumpen pro 1000
Haushalte 2022 da sehen wir das
Deutschland da in orange eingezeichnet
im international Vergleich gerade auch
mit skandinavischen Ländern im Vergleich
relativ schwach da steht
ja hier war lange Zeit Gas sehr sehr
günstig und ich glaube wir spüren auch
wie sehr wir gerade der gaslobby auf die
Füße treten also doll wie war noch
keinem anderen Gesetz da ist jetzt ein
richtiger gegensturm die haben da sehr
sehr viel gutes Geld verdient und die
wollen gerne weiter im Wärmebereich ihr
Gas an den Mann und an die Frau bekommen
und wir haben hier tatsächlich ein ein
großes Potenzial und unabhängiger zu
machen auf erneuerbare zu setzen und
auch Kosten Sicherheit für die Menschen
zu erreichen und die Menschen auch genau
bei dieser Umstellung zu unterstützen
auch Förderung gibt es ja heute schon
für Wärmepumpen und wir hätten sie so
gerne würden sie sogar noch
weiterentwickeln wenn Sie mitmachen auch
die SPD ist da ja an unserer Seite dass
wir sagen wir uns gerne auch noch mal
sozial gestaffelt machen dass die Leute
mit wenig Geld noch mal extra was
bekommen aber auch heute stehen schon 13
Milliarden Förderung bereit für
Wärmepumpen Wärmenetzen Sanierung um die
Leute eben genau bei dieser Umstellung
nicht allein zu lassen weil das ist
natürlich genau unser Ansatz ja zu sagen
da wo sowieso neu investiert wird ja da
muss man eben gleich ins richtige und
investieren und da unterstützen wir die
Leute gleiches richtig zu investieren
und damit haben wir ja ein sehr
sozialverträgliches Instrument das ist
aber Stück für Stück unabhängig macht
ja ich möchte gerne
wenn Sie nicht nur auf die
Berichterstattung Dritter Medien
reparieren würden dann müssten sie aus
den 40 Fragen die die FDP bereits in dem
laufenden Prozess zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz eingereicht haben hat dass
wir sehr wohl Änderungsbedarf beim
förderungs-richtlinien Sehen bei den
Wärmepumpen es ist immer nur die halbe
Wahrheit also Norwegen wird gern als
Beispiel herangehen Norwegen braucht pro
Haushalt pi mal Daumen drei bis viermal
mehr Strom als Deutschland
pro Haushalt das ist also man kann es
immer nicht so Portal vergleichen
norwegen hat sehr viel günstiger
erneuerbaren Strom aus Wasserkraft und
das haben wir nicht deswegen sind die
etwas großzügiger bei der Frage wie
Strom verbraucht wird nichtsdestotrotz
die Wärmepumpe ist eine sehr gute
Technik die wird sich auch durchsetzen
nur wir haben jetzt relativ wenig
Wärmepumpen im Schlaf in Deutschland
weil der Staat wieder mal eine
Technologie präferiert hat in dem Fall
war es halt die Gasbrennwerttherme so
und sich nicht die Leute die für Sie am
besten geeignete Technik haben aussuchen
lassen und deswegen ist Technologie
Aufenthalt kein Fetisch der FDP sondern
wir sehen in vielen Sachen dass da wenn
immer der Staat eine Technologie
präferiert oder festlegen das ist immer
Ergebnis nix hilft uns konkret zu machen
vor 15 Jahren hat der Stadt meinem Vater
gesagt warum hast du Idioten einen
Ölkessel mach doch ein Gaskessel da eine
Gaskessel gemacht und jetzt sagt der
Staat zu ihm du Idiot warum hast denn
Gaskessel jetzt doch lieber Fernwärme
oder Wärmepumpe gemacht deswegen diese
technologieoffenheit ist kein Fetisch
sondern es ist vermeidet viel
Steuerungen
aus staatlicher Sichtung genau das ist
dieses Gesetz ja ne 65% erneuerbare muss
jeder erreichen aber es ist komplett
technologieoffen nur dass wir es ist
einfach die komplette technologieoffen
ja und dann gibt es noch besonders
einfache Option die man besonders
einfach umsetzen kann es setzt bei
weitem nicht nur auf eine Technologie
aber es ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen nicht
immer weiter die falsche Technologie
einzubauen und dann über 20 30 Jahre zu
benutzen es ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen
auch so ein bisschen lernen zu ziehen ja
im letzten Winter waren wir in der
ganzen Mangel nah dran an der
gasmangelage ja alle haben sie
befürchtet wir mussten 55% unseres
Erdgases ersetzen das kann bisher aus
Russland das wird auch absehbare Zeit
nicht mehr aus Russland kommen Putin hat
den Gashand zugedreht so wir haben alle
Register gezogen dass alle Möglichkeiten
genutzt um das zu nutzen um das zu
ersetzen um auch einzusparen und sind
damit heilen durchgekommen aber die
Puffer sind natürlich weg ne wo man
sagen kann so naja wenn es noch mal was
wegfällt wir sind ich finde immer so mal
diese Erd also die Preiskurve für Erdgas
anschaut das ist ein bisschen wie die
Corona Kurve also eine ganz steile
Spitze sowie die Fallzahlen sondern geht
runter nicht mehr auf das niedrigen
Niveau von früher aber relativ tief also
so wie damals im Sommer als alle dann
sagten na ja ach ist vielleicht nicht so
schlimm und dann kam der nächste Herbst
und die Menschen haben ganz zurecht
gesagt ja jetzt müsste die Politik doch
vorbereitet sein und genau in dieser
Zwischenphase sind wir haben diesen
ersten Gaspreis gesehen wir haben 300
Milliarden zur Verfügung gestellt ja wir
können mit einem Bruchteil des Geldes
die Förderung finanzieren so dass die
Leute ohne mehr kosten dann wenn sie
sowieso investieren umstellen und genau
das ist unser Ziel damit wir nicht
unvorbereitet in den nächsten rutschen
und tatsächlich auch die Menschen die so
schnell nicht von der Gasheizung
wegkommen ja die vielleicht vor fünf
Jahren eine eingebaut haben gerade nicht
nur investieren können das für die genug
Gas übrig ist indem es eben nicht die
verbrennen die gerade irgendwas neues
einbauen und wie gesagt alle
Technologien sind an der Stelle möglich
von äh technologieoffenheit möchte ich
jetzt noch mal auf einen Instrument
kommen
ganz kurz ich muss zeitlich noch
die technologieoffenheit ist uns halt
wichtig und ich weiß das nicht jeder
Zuschauer die 177 Seiten gelesen haben
wird es ist müßig über Gas zu reden also
wir steigen aus den fossilen aus das ist
ja klar wie Kloßbrühe deswegen ist also
wir kann er jetzt noch lang über
gasphilosophieren
bringt uns nicht weiter machen wir gar
nicht der großmarktpreis Gas ist derzeit
wieder günstiger als vor dem Krieg aber
das ist gar nicht mehr Punkt der Punkt
ist ich weiß nicht wie man dann sagen
kann es sei technologieoffen wenn zum
Beispiel Holzpellet im Neubau verboten
ist ich weiß nicht wie man sagen kann
wenn die dekaronisierung von gasnetzen
ganz andere Vorgaben bekommen als die
fernbedienzeittechnologie offen ich weiß
noch nicht wie man sagen kann das war
seit technologieoffen wenn man bei
bestimmten Techniken eh 40 Standard
erreichen muss weil der Wärmepumpe nicht
ähm seitigen offen wenn man bei
bestimmten Technologien als zweites
System
technologieoffen deswegen schließen wir
uns den Kritikern an die sagen nein es
ist nicht technologieoffen und da haben
wir die Fachleute aus Sanitär aus
Handwerk aus der Heizungsindustrie der
kommunalunternehmer der Versorger
auf unsere Seite mittlerweile auch ein
edenhofen und die Frau Professor Grimm
es ist nicht technologieoffenes Gesetz
und es wird auch nicht technologieoff
nur weil man sagt das ist ein gutes
Stichwort ich würde jetzt einmal
auf die Uhr
einmal nämlich auch noch mal über
Grimm sprechen die spricht nämlich auch
über den Emissionshandel und das ist ja
für die FDP auch immer wieder ein
zentraler Punkt wenn es um Klimaschutz
geht und was Frau Grimm darunter
versteht das hat sie einmal für uns
zusammengefasst
ja ich glaube man muss das wegen neu
denken weil die politische Diskussion ja
schon in die Richtung zeigt dass man
jetzt große Gruppen von den
Anforderungen ausnehmen wird erst war
von Personen über 80 Jahren die rede
jetzt ist von der Gruppe der rentener
die Rede aber wenn man die Rentner
ausnimmt dann wird man letztlich auch
den Klimaschutzzielen hier nicht gerecht
die ja eigentlich erreicht werden sollen
mit dem Gesetz
deswegen wäre es sinnvoll kommt parallel
zu dem Gesetz auch den Emissionshandel
im Gebäudebereich im Wärmebereich
anzuschärfen man kann dann die
Emissionsreduktionsziele mit Hilfe eines
Zertifikate Handels erreichen man gibt
einfach so viele Emissionsberechtigungen
aus wie die
Emissionsreduktionsziele der
Bundesregierung eben zulassen das führt
dazu wenn man diese
Emissionsberechtigungen handelt das dann
ein CO2-Preis entsteht der die Knappheit
anzeigt jetzt wird man dadurch Einnahmen
generieren durch diesen CO2-Handel und
diese Einnahmen das ist der Vorschlag
von einigen Ökonomen könnte man dann
über ein sogenanntes Klima Geld pro Kopf
an die Bevölkerung zurückgeben das heißt
jeder bekäme gleich viel erstattet aber
die Menschen zahlen in Abhängigkeiten
ihres
CO2-Ausstoßes unterschiedlich viel für
die CO2
Emissionen die sie verursachen
typischerweise haben Leute im unteren
Einkommensbereich weniger CO2-Emissionen
als Leute im oberen Einkommensbereich
und das würde bedeuten dass bei so einem
System die unteren Einkommensklassen
netto gut da stehen würden die würden
netto teilweise sogar profitieren und
die oberen Einkommensklassen würden eben
durch diese pro kopferstattung etwas
entlastet aber würden durchaus noch
einen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz zahlen das
ist das System das vorgeschlagen wird
das System hat eben den Vorteil dass es
die
Emissionsreduktionsziele erreicht aber
gleichzeitig eben auch sozialabfedert
und vor allen Dingen im Schnitt die
unteren Einkommensklassen entlastet
ja das ist Frau Grimms Vorschlag sie ist
Wirtschaftsweise zum Thema
Emissionshandel verbunden mit einem
daraus entstehenden Klimagerät pro Kopf
das erinnert mich ja eigentlich ein
bisschen an eine grüne Idee oder Frau
Nestler ja das Klimagerät ist eine gute
Idee und auch wir wünschen uns ein Klima
Geld weil wie Frau Grimm sagt ist zum
einen hilft Klimaschutz zu bekommen aber
zum anderen tatsächlich auch im Schnitt
die unteren Einkommensklassen entlastet
das ist gut das ist aber kein Ersatz für
ein Gebäude Energiegesetz zum einen
haben etwas ganz anderes vereinbart und
das kann man jetzt nicht einfach im
letzten Meter umdrehen es ist aber auch
und ich meine auch von Veronika Grimm
sagt das ist kein Ersatz ist alleine
über so ein Klima Geld zu gehen würde
tatsächlich Menschen viel viel größere
finanzielle Lasten aufbürden also zum
einen die ganzen Mieter ja der müssen
die Mieter die teure CO2 Kosten zahlen
und die Vermieter wahrscheinlich
trotzdem die günstige Heizung einbauen
ein großes Dilemma aber man würde ja
auch heizen für alle teuer machen ja
auch für die die vor fünf Jahren eine
Gasheizung eingebaut haben und die
gerade gar nicht wirklich die Chance
haben zu wechseln weil das Ding ja noch
fast neu ist und erstmal abbezahlt
werden muss für die würde man heizen
genauso teurer machen obwohl die gerade
nicht die Chance haben zu wechseln da
ist unser Gesetzentwurf viel zielgenauer
ja weil da sagt nur da wo man eh Geld in
die Hand nimmt und dann unterstützen wir
euch noch dabei deswegen ist es sozial
viel gerechter würde man alleine über
das Klima Geld gehen würde mal zwei im
Schnitt die unteren Einkommensklassen
entlasten aber man hätte eben viele
Härtefälle dabei wo unsere
Einkommensklassen viel viel zahlen
müssen und keine Chance haben daraus zu
kommen
nervösst
wir das FDP sind sehr große Fans des
CO2-Zertifikate Handels und der
Gebäudesektor wird ja glaube ich
spätestens 2027 in den europäischen
Zertifikate Handel aufgenommen und das
ist sehr gut sehr sehr gut aber da haben
jetzt die Frau Nestl und ich dann
vielleicht doch noch ein Konsens am Ende
der Sendung der CO2 Zertifikate Handel
mit Klimagerät wird schon mal ein
Regelungsrahmen im Gebäude Energie nicht
ersetzen aber momentan ist ja überhaupt
nicht berücksichtigt überhaupt nicht und
deshalb halten wir für sehr sehr wichtig
dass das mit reinkommt übrigens das ist
ja auch nicht nur Frau Professor Grimm
diese sagt auch Professor Edenhofer vom
Potsdam Institut für Klima Forschung ja
auch ein Top korrigiert der das sagt es
gibt noch so viel offene Punkte im
Gebäude Energiegesetz und darüber reden
wir gerade ein Punkt zum Umlagen des
co2-preises auf die Mieter weil ich weiß
das haben nicht alle mitbekommen
wir haben ein Gesetz beschlossen als
Ampel extrem unbeliebt bei Vermietern
dass wir die CO2 Kosten aufteilen
zwischen Mieter und Vermieter je nachdem
wie schlecht das Gebäude ist also
schlechte Gebäude mit hohem CO2 Ausstoß
muss der Vermieter mehr CO2 übernehmen
gutes Gebäude mit niedrigen CO2-Ausstoß
da wird der Verbrauch wichtiger also zum
Fenster rausheizen muss der Mieter mehr
CO2 übernehmen und das zusammen mit dem
Gebäude Energiegesetz und ähm die CO2
Zertifikate handelt sind drei sehr sehr
sehr wirkmächtige Mechanismen und die
müssen wir aber verschränken und nicht
das GG einfach Stände alone machen
ich möchte hier einmal einen Haken was
ich da gerade schon sowas wie ein leiser
Konsens zum Ende hin dieses Gesprächs
angedeutet hat da habe ich nämlich noch
einen Tipp vom Oppositionsführer mehr
März der da auch noch eine Idee für die
Ampelkoalition hat es wäre gut wenn der
Bundeskanzler bald möglich die Führung
dieser Koalition übernimmt und dafür
sorgt dass dieses Chaos ein Ende hat
Frau Nestler wie stehen Sie dazu
muss der Kanzler hier ein Machtwort
sprechen weil sonst nicht mehr
weitergeht in der Koalition der Kanzler
hat sich ja am Wochenende schon klar
geäußert er hat gesagt wie wichtig ist
ist und das ist ihm persönlich wichtig
ist dass diese Verhandlungen jetzt
beginnen ja weil es ihm wichtig ist dass
das Wort in dieser Ampel etwas gilt und
Herr Fürst es ist schon extrem spannend
dass sie jetzt einfach so tun als wäre
das völlig normal ja was sie hier machen
obwohl der Kanzler am Wochenende ganz
klar gesagt hat ja diese Verhandlung
müssen jetzt beginnen und das soll
schnell verhandelt werden und obwohl
klar vereinbart ist soll vor der
Sommerpause beendet werden und alle
wissen das normale Verfahren kann dann
nur jetzt losgehen das ist schon sehr
dreist sehr lächelt einfach so tun als
wäre es völlig normal wenn Absprachen
nicht gelten und in einer Demokratie
müssen Absprachen gelten sonst kann das
nicht funktionieren wir stehen den
Verantwortung für ein sehr großes ein
sehr wichtiges ein sehr schönes Land ja
und darf müssen Absprachen auch gelten
ja und ähm ich meine jetzt auch ruhig
noch einen Schritt weiter muss der
Kanzler denn da von sein Herr Fürst ja
bitte ich war heute zum dritten Mal in
einem zwei Stunden Verhandlungsteam zum
Verhandlungstermin zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz ich weiß nicht woher die
Grünen die Erzählung haben es würde
nicht verhandelt ich war da heute selber
von 39 bis 11:30 Uhr genau im Kopf hat
mit Wirtschaftsministerium mit
Bauministerium mit SPD Grünen und FDP
also ich weiß nicht wo dieser Erzählung
herkommt wir würden nicht verhandeln wir
haben bereits 40 Fragen in die Debatte
eingebracht was in der Bild-Zeitung
steht steht in der Bild-Zeitung wenn sie
sich daran aber Arbeiten verlässlich ist
es okay aber dann lassen sich gerne die
Fragen geben die als FDP bereits
gestellt wurden
wir stellen das Gesetz nicht in Frage
stellen Frage wir halten nur die erste
Lesung jetzt in zwei Tagen falsch ich
habe noch eine abschließende Frage an
Herrn für zu diesem Zeitpunkt dieser
Intervention
der FDP weil man könnte ja auch darüber
nachdenken wenn dieses Gesetz jetzt
nicht mehr vor der Sommerpause wenn sich
da nicht mehr auf etwas einheitliches
geeinigt wird dann wird das Ganze ja
auch wieder Thema nach dem Sommer und
dann ist es ja auch gar nicht mehr so
lange hin zu den Landtagswahlen in
Hessen und Bayern spielt das nicht auch
eine Rolle in diesen Machenschaften FDP
da gerade
jetzt sage ich mal als Bayer wir müssen
uns in der Bundespolitik losmachen von
den Landtagswahlkämpfen wir sind in
Deutschland ständig in einem Wahlkampf
wenn wir Gesetzgebung nach
landtagswahlterminen machen werden wir
nie gute Gesetze hinbekommen und auch
wenn vereinbart wurde dass dieses Gesetz
vor der Sommerpause kommen soll sogar
Robert Habeck der Wirtschaftsministerium
selbst hat ja gesagt er kann auch mit
2027 leben aber wenn es vor der
Sommerpause kommen soll dann muss bitte
jeden klar sein dass die FDP kein
beliebig Geschlechtlichkeit beliebig
schlechtes Gesetz unterschreibt wir
haben große Bedenken wie auch viele
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger wie auch
viele Fachleute damit große Bedenken
dass dieses Gesetz machbar praktikabel
und bezahlbar ist und deswegen werden
wir so lange diskutieren müssen bis es
ein gutes Gesetz wird sie wissen ganz
genau dass der Kanzler meinte dass die
erste Lesung in dieser Woche stattfinden
soll ja und sie wissen außerdem ganz
genau dass nie in Frage stand und das
ist ganz klar geklärt ist dass die
Behandlungen vor der Sommerpause zu Ende
sein sollen ja es ist auch klar geeint
wann das in Kraft treten soll zum ersten
ersten 24 aber wenn Sie jetzt hier noch
so die 27 reinmischen ja das hat
überhaupt
sorry sie haben das gerade hier ins
Gespräch eingebracht ja und ich ordne
einfach
eine einmal diese Zahl abgesehen davon
ja das ist so tatsächlich überhaupt
nicht gesagt worden ist die einmal ein
ja es geht dabei um die Frage wann das
Gesetz in Kraft treten nicht wann es
fertig verhandelt ist es stand nie in
Frage es ist eindeutig kein die
Koalitionsausschuss das ist vor der
Sommerpause fertig verhandelt sein soll
und das ist aber offensichtlich eine
andere Frage als wann die einzelnen
Regelung für einzelne Gruppen in Kraft
treten ja und auch da hat er nicht die
27 genannt aber er der ins zentrale
Punkt ist doch dass ich einfach will
Zahlen durcheinander mischen um den
Eindruck zu erwecken ja das was der
Kanzler explizit gesagt hat was nicht
passieren soll woher Mütze nicht der
Fraktionschef der SPD sich gestern
extrem genervt gezeigt hat ja weil sie
schlichtweg das was gemeinsam vereinbart
ist nicht einhalten dass sie versuchen
dass du darzustellen den Sie
irgendwelche Zahlen reinmischen ja die
gar nichts damit zu tun haben als sei
das normal und für uns ist es nicht zum
fünften Mal dass die Verhandlung
beginnen müssen dann sage ich zum
fünften Mal verhandeln und weil wir uns
anfangen uns hier zu wiederholen muss
ich einmal ähm
wenn ein gutes Gesetz wird dann kommt ja
schnell ich weiß nicht wie es Euch da
draußen geht aber so richtig nach
Einigung sieht das jetzt hier nach
dieser Diskussion doch nicht aus ich
bedanke mich trotzdem bei Ihnen für
diese lebhafte Diskussion vielen Dank
danke auch schönen Abend
ja also ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
aber das klingt auf jeden Fall danach
als ob diese ampelzhaft noch ein
bisschen weitergeht werde jetzt mit wem
wann verhandelt wir bleiben auf jeden
Fall weiterhin für euch dran und ich
gucke zum Schluss noch mal in die
Kommentare was ihr so dazu denkt und
eure Meinung zum Thema ist ziemlich
gemischt hier schreibt auf Youtube ein
User ich hoffe die FDP bekommt bei den
nächsten Landtagswahlen die Quittung für
dieses kindische Verhalten das sind die
Landtagswahlen die ich eben angesprochen
habe ähm hier schreibt noch jemand ich
bin genervt von der FDP und ihrem
Verhalten die kleinste Partei macht das
Maul immer am weitesten auf egal warum
hier schreibt aber auch jemand ich finde
dieses geplante Gesetz eine
Unverschämtheit sondern gleichen denn
das CO2 das eingespart werden soll hätte
man genauso einsparen können wenn man
die sicheren AKWs hätte weiterlaufen
lassen ja Thema Energiewende in
Deutschland ihr seht ihr seid euch
uneinig die Koalition ist sich irgendwie
auch noch uneinig wie das Ganze
weitergeht wir bleiben für euch dran ich
danke euch für eure Kommentare und bis
zum nächsten Mal